hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
going to be a Justice League movie video
Jeff John just explained some things
already doing his job way better than we
ever hoped he would just making
everybody feel better about what's going
on with the DC movie universe so this is
actually really exciting it is so funny
how Geoff Johns has turned into the
Chuck Norris of the DC Universe they're
gonna be like Geoff Johns facts after
this so Geoff Johns in typical fashion
flying in with the white light of
creation fixing your weekend plans as he
clears up what's going on with Justice
League no one really understood what the
Justice League movies title was going to
be so there were a bunch of different
possibilities Geoff Johns just flew in
was like no no no it's not going to be
called any of those it's just going to
be called
Justice League so late last night you
hear this collective sigh of relief
because all the titles that people were
wondering about were complete nightmare
fuel each worse than the last
so first fake title Justice League
United doesn't sound too bad okay sounds
like the team's coming together next big
title angels and demons okay starting to
get a little religious here sounds like
that Dan Brown Tom Hanks sequel movie
that was pretty terrible so getting a
little worried here starting to get a
little worried next title gods among us
okay sounds familiar
there was the video game they did the
spin-off comic book problem is most
people have probably forgotten how
dystopian this take on the characters
was it was like a vast departure from
the normal comic books in that it was so
much grittier and darker so what was the
big criticism against Batman V Superman
did it lacked hope this title implies
that they would push even deeper into
that so you're just like oh my god then
kind of taking that religious idea and
the gods among us idea combining them
gods among men so sounds pretty serious
so you can see how just going with the
title Justice League as Jeff John says
it's just way better
it's way simpler because I feel like
Batman V Superman dawn of Justice is the
longest title that you could possibly
come up with for a movie like most of
the coverage of the movie just dropped
the dawn of Justice like we don't need
to subtitle it just call it Batman V
Superman or Batman vs Superman but there
are a whole bunch of other reasons why
the title just completely didn't work
for the movie because Batman isn't
necessarily fighting Superman even
though that's the way they
the movie but they're just sidestepping
all those problems because Geoff Johns
wrote in just like everybody feel better
about this we're going to call it
Justice League it's going to feel like a
Justice League movie should so they're
shooting that right now and just to
catch everybody up on what's going on
when Justice League picks up so we'll
say spoilers for the end of Batman V
Superman in case you haven't seen that
but what happens is is Superman is
presumed dead even though we all know
he's coming back but Batman the reason
they said they did that at the end of
the movie is because they wanted Batman
to have to assemble the Justice League
with the help of Wonder Woman so Batman
is going to be going around to all the
different Justice League members trying
to convince them to join the fight
because of this unnamed threat that they
sense is coming thanks to some extra
footage they released after the movie
this like kind of Justice League teaser
here with Darkseid mother boxes we know
that Lex Luthor also has an idea for
what's coming but until we see some
production art we really don't know how
they're going to portray the forces of
apocalypse you know the flip side of
that we don't really know if they're
going to be doing a lot of the New Gods
because the way they're pitching it
right now it sounds like the Justice
League formed to fight off Darkseid in
the forces of apocalypse even though the
new gods usually help them out at some
point when their comic book stories
where this happens but it's supposed to
be two movies Justice League part one
Justice League part two I'm assuming
they're going to change the title for
Part two if they're just going to call
the first Justice League movie Justice
League so they'll probably will be a
subtitle for the second one but the
first one I'm just expecting them to
assemble the Justice League will
actually see what's going on with
Darkseid and apocalypse whoever the tip
of that spear is going to be by the time
we get to the second movie that'll be
like full-on war between the Justice
League in Darkseid so if you want to
read a big Justice League dark side
story surprise surprise Geoff Johns just
wrote a really awesome story called
Darkseid war which is basically like the
anti-monitor versus Darkseid craziest
best idea for a comic book batch up ever
two of the most powerful people in the
DC universe just slugging it I just
being the out of each other so that
was all before DC rebirth so that story
isn't connected to what's going on at DC
rebirth it kind of exists in the world
before the big rebirth event but if you
haven't yet be sure to read DC rebirth
they do a whole bunch of really awesome
things the flashes at the center of it
in a really awesome way and I will be
doing a new flash video later today I'll
be talking about some of the differences
between the flash movie which is
actually going to be a team-up movie
compared to the flash TV show so be sure
to subscribe to get that I'll name the
giveaway winner whenever I post that and
if you didn't know surprise surprise
weekend just got a little bit better
there is a DC giveaway going on now all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video it's just a $20 Amazon gift card
and if you're still confused about
what's going on now that Geoff Johns is
kind of like the Kevin Feige of DC
that's not a totally accurate term but
that's just the easiest terms that I
could put it in is he's kind of course
correcting the movies so he's the guy
that rides in and explains characters to
people so they don't misuse them so you
don't see Batman or Superman
doing things or acting ways that they
would not act so while you guys wait for
that flash video to post you can click
here to learn about what's going on with
Marvel's phase 3 just do like a complete
big timeline and you can click here to
learn all about what's going on with the
flash season 3 in the flashpoint
storyline thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight